ololé vie correspondant en france de l'
agence de presse italienne à nca bonsoir
paolo levi les cheveux dans le vent
manifestement sur les toits de paris
vous êtes évidemment aux liaisons
constamment avec vos amis italiens vos
compatriotes
quel est l'état d'esprit qui règne en
italie le soulagement mais aussi on
imagine beaucoup de prudence
cela a été très très bien dit depuis
ramené votre correspondante a fait une
photo parfaite c'est à dire un clair
obscur c'est à dire d'un côté l'espoir
voilà et surtout une certaine dose
d'optimisme pour cette étape de
confinement pur et dur qui était
finalement enfin franchi après deux mois
de sacrifices incroyables de la part de
la population moi j'ai eu un copain il
m'a appelé ce matin presque les larmes
aux yeux parce qu'il avait pu pour la
première fois depuis plus de 50 jours
allez dans un café où on va tout le
temps boire des cafés le matin et
prendre son café quoique emporté parce
qu'il pouvait pas le voir au comptoir il
fallait juste prendre un gobelet en
carton et sortir le siroter sur le
trottoir mais vous devez savoir que pour
les italiens le café sèmerait rite
nationale il n'y a pas de journée kid
pas de soleil qui puisse se lever sans
ce café du matin qui est vraiment que
l'emblème même de la société italienne
qui est
voilà qui se redresse chaque matin et va
au travail c'est donc lui il m'a appelé
c'était genre une poésie pour lui il m'a
dit écoute je suis l'âge et rien que ce
groupe me ressemble madeleine
proustienne pas ça faisait 50 jours que
je me faisais le café à la maison qui
bien évidemment est moins bon que celui
du bar à rome et après donc d'un côté
l'optimisme de l'autre aussi la crainte
inquiétude pour une situation qui est
très très fragile
les italiens sont bien conscients que la
phase 2 c'est pas du tout la fin du
confinement hélas il faut faire encore
preuve de de muscles il faut il faut
faire encore un effort parce que le
risque sinon et celui de faire comme
dans le mythe grec de sisyphe comme on
ramène le raccrocher tout haut de la
montagne
et ensuite le heureux rocher à nouveau
tombe dans la vallée il faut recommencer
tout à zéro
donc c'est une cuisine une situation
très délicate on pourrait la comparer à
celle des convalescents qui après la
maladie voilà doivent rester tranquille
encore un petit peu au liés à la maison
sont pas trop faire d'efforts parce que
sinon on risque de voir retomber dans le
confinement et je pense que déjà des
conséquences vont être lourdes issime
pour l'économie et la société italienne
et même un européenne et mondiale le
plus en général
donc c'est vraiment un moment charnière
où on peut pas trop rigoler las il faut
être fort en corse et on a gagné dix ans
après 50 jours une première bataille
contre l'ennemi invisible une bataille
voilà qui était celle du confinement pur
et dur aujourd'hui on s'apprête à à
combattre une deuxième mater et qui est
celle de la phase 2 qui n'est pas la fin
est lasse de la guerre mais voilà on
avance on avance tout doucement ou non
parler vais vous parler de l'économie
des des conséquences alors la calabre à
et la vénitie
autorisé la réouverture des restaurants
et des bars alors sans terrasson précise
parce que dieu seul sait combien c'est
important chez des italiens les
terrasses on imagine que c'est une vraie
catastrophe pour le secteur c'est un
pays avec une culture effectivement très
convivial on se retrouve dans les bars
les restaurants sur sur les cannes à un
désastre
un désastre je parlais avec ma collègue
dança donc de lagence pour laquelle je
travaille les quartier général de mon
agence sont à côté de la fontaine de
trevi et elle elle me dit raconter
aujourd'hui que pour aller au travail
il ya tellement il ya énormément de bar
il doit y avoir ne sais pas comme une
trentaine de bars dans dans un périmètre
tenant deux pâtés de maison presque
tellement normalement la requête des
gros centres touristes et romain et
aujourd'hui voilà ces barres même s'il
pouvait réouvrir et l'été il était
complètement vide parce que il n'ya pas
il n'y a pas la demande
y'a trop d'offres hélas parce que tous
les touristes rome c'est qui est une
ville où si touristique très touristique
s'est vidée de tous ces touristes et je
pense pas qui sait demain la veille
qu'ils vont revenir et un peu partout
non mais on est en train de vivre il
faut en être conscient on est en train
de vivre quelque chose qui est
comparable je pense à la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale aux
destructions et c'est une autre forme de
destruction et de dévastation mais c'est
ça donc d'un côté il faut le savoir
avait créé avec conscience mais en même
temps aussi espérer qu'après après la
guerre il y a aussi une forme la
renaissance et et l'italie dieu et la
france ou si dieu sait si les trente
glorieuses et le miracle italien ensuite
qu'ils n'ont pas apporté
voilà à la croissance et le bien-être
extraordinaire qui a été ensuite jamais
pu égaler en europe en tout cas à
l'époque donc l'espoir c'est de
recommencer mais pour cela il est
fondamental de faire preuve de
solidarité de l'union pas seulement au
niveau national mais même européen et je
dirais même mondial pour la recherche
d'un vaccin qu'il est fondamental aux
autres gros coup dur pour l'économie
italienne les écoles elle reste fermée
jusqu'en septembre les halls et élus
radicaux qu'en france en tout cas moins
hésitant comment les parents justement
gère j'imagine le travail l'école des
enfants parce que kylie enfants la
maison dire la compliquer pour d'aller
travailler évidemment oui ils ont collé
à la société italienne par rapport à la
société française ces deux peuples
frères deux peuples qui ont beaucoup de
points en commun
mais la société italienne et les pep est
plus basé sur la famille donc il y à
tout un réseau familial d'amitié qui est
toujours là c'est notre le vrai où elle
était le vrai état social italien
il se base avant tout sur sur la
solidarité entre membres de la famille
donc je pense que ils peuvent tenir
comme ça et si les parents c'est surtout
les parents qui ont préféré
voilà le gouvernement il a quelque part
traduit une sensation qui est né dans
dans l'air dans le pays c'était celle
que la mama et le papa il n'avait aucune
antipathie d'envoyer les enfants à
l'école avec ses risques qui planent
encore sur notre tête et cet ennemi
invisible qui circulent encore dans dans
nos villes et dans nos pays donc
l'italie a fait ce soit assez radicale
mais on va voir en france qu'est ce que
ça va donner si si si il y aura beaucoup
d'élèves qui vont se présenter à l'école
au bas moi j'ai des doutes franchement
mais c'est vrai que ce que ça va être
très intéressant de voir en tout cas
c'est un casse tête pour les proviseurs
moi j'ai lu des lettres le proviseur ici
dans les écoles à paris c'est rien que
d'un point de vue logistique pour
organiser la sécurité des gosses et
einstein
merci paul ollivier en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
merci à vous